[Musique]
bonjour philippe labi bonjour vous
accompagner au joker utard la petite
fille de robert sans nièce de philippe
hersant dans ce projet de reprise du
groupe antilles guyane medien groupe qui
édite le seul quotidien de nos trois
pays france antilles et france-guyane
philippe la guadeloupe et france
guadeloupe
c'est un dossier sensible avant d'en
parler aujourd'hui que la situation de
ce groupe qui passait déjà par plusieurs
redressement judiciaire par des plans
sociaux
aujourd'hui le groupe comme vous le
savez malheureusement est en cessation
de paiement
donc ce qui veut dire que il voit là le
groupe est endetté dans une situation
financière extrêmement entendu
extrêmement difficile 1 donc il faut il
faut changer les choses il faut relever
la tête et comme on dit ici il faut être
debout c'est pour ça qu'on est là et je
pense en particulier à toutes les
équipes qui sont dans l'inquiétude voire
dans l' angoisse et donc voilà donc la
réalité c'est une réalité économique
extrêmement tendue difficile et il faut
inverser cette donne et c'est pour ça
que vous affichez aujourd'hui en page 3
du quotidien absolument faux il faut
sauver france antilles et comment il
comment s'y prendre justement s'y
prendre déjà premier point c'est ce que
je vous dit à l'instant premier point
c'est s'appuyer sur les équipes
préserver l'emploi rassurer les équipes
et je dirais vraiment avec beaucoup de
respect sans aucun mépris parce qu elle
est angoissée cette équipe elle est
terriblement angoissée elle et les
équipes sont terriblement ou alors ce
qu'ils ont vu ses équipes déjà partir
elles ont vu partir d'autres coulent
elles ont vu partir d'autres collègues
elles sont tétanisés en termes de
management
on voit bien qu'il ya des choses qui
n'ont pas fonctionné donc je ne
m'appesantirai pas là dessus
regardons le futur plutôt que le passé
même si comme dit un proverbe africain
l'homme qui n'a pas de passé n'a pas de
futur
on est néanmoins il faut vraiment penser
au futur donc faut rassurer déjà les
équipes avec un vrai projet d'éditorial
une vraie volonté et une écoute une
écoute encore une fois basées sur le
respect et le dialogue
ça veut dire qu'il faut remettre de
l'est sur le rail alors pourquoi ça
n'existait pas et que ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment je ne veut
accabler personne mais on voit bien
quand même qu'il ya une question je
dirais de fonctionnement de fluidité à
l'intérieur même des équipes qui a un
besoin de deux je dirais de respiration
de voilà de respiration nouvelles des
coûts de nouvelles et que toutes les
équipes travaillent main dans la main
alors aux deux
trop tard a écrit à chaque salarié le 11
avril dernier elle a écrit son amour son
attachement les conditions dans
lesquelles son actionnariat s'exerçait
on la sent frustré et puissante mais
elle veut changer les choses comme en
mai mais bien sûr parce qu'elle est aux
diacres et arrêter une actionnaire
malheureusement comme elle le dit dans
ce courrier tenus à l'écart
donc nice lâche sa famille non mais ce
oui mais ça c'est pas une volonté de sa
part elle a été tenue à la cahc l'écart
donc je ne rentrerai pas dans ces
détails là parce qu'on veut regarder
devant mais elle était clairement tenu à
l'écart elle est minoritaire elle n'a
que 38 % du capital donc comment
pourrait-on lui reprocher d'être de de
ne pas avoir agi alors qu'elle n'a fait
que ça durant toutes ces années et que
là aujourd'hui enfin elle veut aller
beaucoup plus loin et reprendre j'ai mal
et elle est pas too much quand elle joue
presse assure la porte on a fait ça vous
avez raison c'est sûr pas du tout elle
joue pas sur la corde sensible
elle est très liée à son grand père
robert hersant qui a créé ce groupe
notamment incarné par henri manga talent
dont c'était la célébration hier de la
disparition douze ans après on a fait
quelque chose d'intimé entre nous elle
joue pas du tout sur la corde sensible -
pour la connaître assez bien maintenant
c'est pas quelqu'un qui joue non mais
j'insiste sur ce point il n'y a pas de
démagogie il n'y a pas de posture il ya
une réalité il ya une empathie
il ya une écoute il ya une véritable
volonté c'est pas du tout le groupe
perdent des lecteurs
mais le groupe perd de la rentrée avec
les russes aient pu mais je vous avez
raison le site internet qui loin d'être
opprimé c'est tout ça qu'on veut changer
si le groupe perd des lecteurs père de
l'audience perd de l'argent
ce n'est pas la faute de dodge à plus
tard ou de la mienne on vient pour
changer les choses pour investir pour se
donner les moyens pour relancer pour
donner pour redonner toute sa grandeur à
france antilles qui est un média
extrêmement important qu'est le 1er mai
un seul quotidien abstenant les infos il
faut redonner c'est le quotidien des
martiniquais à c'est le quotidien des
guyanais c'est le quotidien des
guadeloupéens
donc il lui faut les heureux dans la
fête non je suis pas dans l'affect c'est
une réalité c'est un lien social et nous
on veut défendre sa et l'indépendance
clip l'avion va se parler franchement
oui pourquoi autant de bruit là
maintenant alors qu'un administrateur et
nommé et qui l'attend sur son bureau
d'autres éventuels candidats au rachat
du groupe et
jusqu'à midi le 28 avril pour se faire
connaître
excellente question est-ce que vous avez
on parle beaucoup de repreneurs
aujourd'hui mais nous sommes les seuls
depuis depuis le début à nous est
prononcée clairement avec un projet
clair précis qu'on va développer vous
agiter le chiffon rouge qu'on nous
sommes là on agite aucun chiffon rouge
on essaye de faire les choses posément
calmement sereinement
il n'y a aucune volonté de précipitation
mais ont travaillé le dossier parce
qu'ils les existe d'autres repreneurs
c'est une excellente question je vous
êtes journaliste moi aussi on parle de
beaucoup de j'entends dire ici ou là
j'entends parler de croisade maire
concernant français certains opérateurs
privés rêve de ce grand groupe
audiovisuel avec à la fois une radio une
télévision et presse écrite et même
cinéma mais nous avons en face de nous
on ne rêve pas de ça nous on rêve de
remettre france antilles au coeur ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on veut
travailler le papier autant que le
numérique on veut pas opposés l'un à
l'autre je vais être précis si vous me
donnez quelques secondes ça veut dire
qu'il faut réfléchir activement et
rapidement au passage en quadrichromie
comment se fait-il que france on dit
aujourd'hui ce quotidien là n'est pas
totalement pourri commis comme le sont
des des quotidiens notamment métro il
faut tout dans laquelle on pourrait se
reconnaître vraiment avec des photos
avec de l'encré avec le granit et
d'impression avec le choix des visuels
avec un vrai travail d'artisanat qu'il
faut remettre au coeur je dirais de
france en titre ça c'est la première
chose développer le papier mais aussi
bien évidemment le numérique il ya une
petite équipe il faut la renforcer il
faut la déployer il faut qu'on ait plus
de moyens sur le numérique ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut
penser réfléchir en terme de vidéo par
exemple en termes de production en
termes de blogs il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire sur le numérique mais ça nous
avons un les équipes qu'il faut sans
doute déployer et redéployer sans doute
formé d'autres du bois travaillé
ensemble et chaque corporation ap se
respecte au sein même de france entier
c'est là-bas que c'est souvent à cause
de l'autre que ça fonctionne mais cesse
mais vous savez se dit c'est absolument
pas notre philosophie absolument pas la
mienne notre volonté c'est de donner un
horizon et de faire ensemble que les
gens craquent de faire que les gens
travaillent ensemble est réellement
ensemble se respecte il n'y a pas d'un
côté les fonctionnaires blé les
fonctions pas noble donc vraiment où sa
capitale il faut remettre du vivre
ensemble et du travaillant ensemble au
sein même de france antilles mais à la
décharge des équipes aussi elles ont été
malmenées à cause du management
elles ont été malmenées vous allez
changer le management on va établir des
règles du jeu
des rédacteurs en chefs qui font un
travail fantastique il ya des équipes
qui sont vraiment à l'âge dirais au
labeur chaque jour donc seul il faut les
valoriser les écouter mais en tout cas
il faut sortir d'un certain état
d'esprit et c'est ça qu'on veut rétablir
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra revoir également
les circuits de distribution alors il ya
beaucoup de choses de vente
évidemment l'abonnement numérique tout
simplement elle se serait dit que ça
fonctionnait il faut que les il faut
déjà que la qualité du contenu soit
exemplaire ce quelques âmes et on va
renforcer davantage il faut ensuite
évidemment que la qualité je dirais des
livraisons et des points de livraison
soit parfaitement assurée donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut vérifier les points de
vente
ensuite il faut vérifier la qualité des
abonnements donc un vrai sujet avec les
abonnés le respect niveau pour l'inter
mais vous pourrez pour l'externe ça veut
dire qu'on respecte nos lecteurs et nos
usagers et vous croyez vraiment au
succès de la presse écrite aujourd'hui
en 2017 alors que d'autres grands
groupes avec plus de moyens n'y arrive
pas c'est pas vrai parce que quand vous
regardez des quotidiens des c'est tout
c'est une affaire d'alchimie et de
composer d'euros proposition il ya une
place pour le lectorat notamment au mas
principalement même aux antilles où il
ya un électorat qui est attachée à son
support papier mais il faut travailler
c'est sans doute pas les mêmes tonalités
mais il faut travailler le papier et le
numérique
donc là dessus c'est absolument
compatible on voit bien on a des
exemples en france en métropole mais
aussi à l'étranger
donc il faut redéployer avoir un vrai
projet éditorial et on va investir
ce qu'il faut comprendre et condat soir
l'acquisition mais je la perche combier
d'argent madame jeu jacques witt a déjà
sur la thaïlande mettra de l'argent
qu'il faudra pour relancer elle mettra
l'argent qui va quand même pas
l'intention de ne pas me donner de
chiffres vous allez me dire combien je
peux pas vous dire le chiffre
aujourd'hui parce que ça serait
c'est prématuré mais on va investir des
moyens conséquents très conséquents pour
les équipes pour le matériel je vous ai
parlé de l'imprimerie mais ça veut dire
aussi pour le numérique pour le
marketing pour tous on va aller leur
seuil minimal philippe mabillard de sade
quelle somme ce n'est même pas la peine
d'y aller mais aujourd'hui c'est
prématuré de répondre à cette question
je veux dire il ya bien il faut mettre
des moyens conséquents et on mettra ses
moyens conséquents
est ce que vous n'avez pas pris un
risque ce matin de venir chez nous ici
dans le studio de la première aux
affichant sur le france antilles vous
avez acheté cette campagne d'affichage
est ce que vous ne l'avez pas le risque
de vous faire taper sur les doigts par
l'administrateur
non pas du tout on est en démocratie
c'est purement légale de venir on agit
de manière transparente de manière
claire à visage découvert donc je vois
pas pourquoi on prendrait un risque on a
rencontré l'administrateur judiciaire on
ans dont on est dans une démarche
d'apaisement
on est dans une démarche de construction
mais vous imposer le tempo quand même
mais attendait mais on connaît à peu
vous êtes jour n'est ce pas aussi on
connaît notre métier on essaye quand
même de d'avoir un dialogue serein
fécond et non pas d' imposer notre tempo
mais de faire en sorte que notre projet
qui est extrêmement important pour le
devenir de france antilles soit pérenne
soit entendue soit audible
donc merci de m'avoir invité nous on
veut se faire entendre merci ce sera le
mot de la fin est philippe labi rappelle
que vous accompagnez ocak louis tard
petite fille de robert sens dans ce
projet de reprise du groupe antilles
guyane mhidia antilles guyane médias qui
publient france antilles et france
guyane merci bonne journée merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
des critères